let me uh let me let me ask you
congressman
do you think that uh should republicans
regain control of the assuming they do
regain control of the house probably the
senate should there be an investigation
into the 2020 riots maybe i i know you
mentioned there's probably not gonna be
a lot of energy towards these things
because they're old but i feel like we
need resolution there should be uh
because i think a lot of the agitators
in the 2020 rights what we're finding
out is many of these people are being
paid they're not even from the
neighborhood they're being bussed in
they're being called in they're being
paid by these organizations on the far
left to go out there and do damage and
hurt our country uh if you saw what took
place here a couple weeks ago when they
when they had the leak with the supreme
court ruling the roe versus wade you saw
some of the things in in i think it was
in california some place maybe la that
seems to be the and and there were cop
cars that had windows being smashed and
i'm like the knucklehead break in that
window on that car has no earthly idea
what the hell roe versus wade is
he he doesn't he has no clue he he has
been paid they get these individuals and
they rally the horses they pay them to
go out there and spin things up and stir
things up and that's the problem you
have with the far left is there's no
civility there they want to go
immediately to violence and it's
dangerous in this country and and so
this deal coming up here with the with
this potential uh uh
with the uh supreme court with roe
versus wade i mean it's gonna get ugly i
think national guard needs to be
deployed it's already gotten ugly
they've been firebombing uh clinics that
are set up to help pregnant women so so
um
they announced the supreme court will be
adding another
opinion day
tomorrow
and as soon as i heard that i was like
you got to be kidding me here we go
that's when they're going to do it
aren't they and anybody who's ever
covered riots so all the journalists out
there the the riot squad i've been on
the ground you know the worst possible
day is friday
because everyone's off work and they got
the weekend students out of school they
got the weekend
so if they do come out tomorrow morning
and say rowan casey you're gone
they may be thinking you do it on a
friday because then no one no one in the
media picks it up but the lunatics are
waiting
they're waiting with baited breath
it's going to be 10 45 that's when they
issue usually the last opinion around 10
40 and they're going to say row in case
you're gone and then you are going to
see tomorrow night if they do this
bonkers riots and then saturday insanity
and guys if you need somewhere place to
a safe to hide out on saturday and
you're in new york city the beacon
theater
festival.mines.com it's big theater
sturdy wall that's where some of the
worst ryan is going to be
they're going to be like where's tim
yeah
yeah i just i'm i'm just realizing this
right now i mean we didn't know we had
this event's been playing for a long
time
we're going to be it's not just us james
o'keefe tulsi gabbard yeah uh
you're gonna have a lot of people there
seth dylan's gonna be there this is the
making of an action movie yeah where
it's like we are gonna get locked in and
either turn on each other or become the
heroes new york city has been waiting
for someone's gonna eat the last
snickers they're gonna be like it's him
he's a liberal he's one of them i'll be
like he's a russian asset and then we
just keep going back and forth this is
yeah i mean they riot they're encouraged
to ride as you mentioned one of my
favorite lines that we kept hearing
repeatedly was rioting is the language
of the unheard if only we were hearing
them they wouldn't be writing and then
they turn around and they go we have to
silence conservatives or else they'll
commit acts of violence it's like well
hold on a second hold on a second you're
like concerned about violence from
conservatives so you want to make them
unheard because you just told me like
writing is what people do when they
aren't heard so what do you believe i
just want to i just want to stress this
one more time like
they added an extra day to do opinions
tomorrow and it seems like it may be
like why else would they do that they
have the next week to do the final
opinions they could do it on monday
and so i'm like we're gonna be in new
york and it's gonna be like it's gonna
be like dawn of the dead yeah we're
gonna be locked in and there's gonna be
like they're outside they got the power
lines and
we have votes tomorrow morning
mid-morning they should have probably
waited till we're out of here maybe they
won't do it though maybe what they're
trying to do is teach
no they're trying i think there's like
16 more opinions
maybe they're trying to be like we need
to get all this out on on on monday yeah
so that means tomorrow we should do
these ones then monday we can do roe v
wade the holiday weekend wait for over
the four years yeah yeah i agree maybe
oh yeah people won't be paying attention
maybe well or whatever crazy people are
the crazy people will be um but it's not
a holiday weekend it's it's it's a
holiday month it's maaga month that's
right yeah maga month the month of july
we got to change all of our profile
pictures to american flags and celebrate
america okay
and i'm okay with that
and we grill every day that's right
every day and then and then on the
fourth of july you have the fireworks
but yeah mug a month
i'm ready i'm not even kidding i'm legit
like we are done
buddy i'm moving anyways
i ordered uh what did i order uh
fireworks i hope how many hot dogs did i
order 100
100
what is this yeah i think i ordered 100
hot dogs or is it 500 no it's not 500 i
think that's what i'm moving my stuff
from austin i'm going to have to change
my plans i'm going to it's all month bro
oh it's all months we're going to be
firing up the grill all month this is
awesome so i ordered this big thing from
portillo's famous chicago hot dogs every
day baby and so we're going to be
grilling moving here is the best
decision i've ever made this is awesome
everyone's going to be chilling that's
work maga month baby yeah we celebrate
america oh my goodness what were we
talking about i wanted to get a little
optimistic gun supreme court protesting
man i also you know it it's just
we
i feel like the the writing is sort of
the on the street
equivalent of what happens on twitter
where it's like do you actually want
something to get done right if you
actually want something to get done
you're gonna want to talk to people
you're good for example so i got
not many i've gotten and i thank all of
you listening i've gotten thousands of
new followers on on twitter and to the
podcast since i've started coming on
this show but i've lost a couple
of vocal fans of mine who are on the
left
and they would just say stuff about you
that
was hyperbolic but also that i would
disagree with and they were like how
could you be on a show with that person
and it's like hey man if you think we
disagree on that
wouldn't you actually think it was a
great thing for me to be on the show for
me to bring a diverse viewpoint for me
to become friends with someone who
maybe i will even see my point of view
like sometimes i see his point of view
and they don't care no they will not
listen and yeah and that's that's where
i'm at so there's uh we've got this
lefty guy who's going to be speaking on
the same panel as us in uh at the beacon
theater and he had to put out a video
explaining why he was doing it
he called it a debate and so i got a
message from this like left-wing guy
that i that i'm friends with and he's
like you're debating this dude and i was
like i'm not debating anybody we're
talking about like it's a panel on media
manipulation we're just hanging
i mean i'm gonna sit there and be like i
don't know like i don't i don't i don't
like debating people i'll argue with
someone i'll try to correct them if i
think they're wrong but i don't enter
debates i don't like invite people here
to debate me i don't do any of that
stuff i just let's have a conversation
it's a hang it's a conversation but the
fact that he even had to make a video
addressing it being like here's why i'm
doing it and then people responded with
like yeah but dude it's james o'keefe
like what's wrong with you it's okay
whatever dude i don't look i don't i
don't want to live that way i don't i i
like i like being able to walk in a room
with anybody and be like tell me stuff
yes
it appears to me that the american
people can't seem to to be able to sit
across the table from each other like
this and have and agree to disagree yes
and and what we're teaching our kids in
my humble opinion when
when you see what took place with the
summer rides in 2020 it seems like if we
disagree now we just all of a sudden we
curl up our fists and we hit each other
in the nose and i think it's it's going
in the wrong direction what are we
teaching our kids what are we teaching
these these kids to think hey if you
can't resolve you just go in there and
hit him in the nose and and 20 20 was
bad but we are one tim we are one police
shooting away uh from having an enormous
civil unrest i mean if it's if it's a
white officer that shoots an
african-american and there's any
questionable call there al sharpton has
his plane on the tarmac it's ready to go
he's going to fire that thing up he's
going to fire he's going to fly to that
area and he's just going to go in there
and he's going to be an agitator it's
it's and it's sad well that's not the
way we should handle things it's not
even about if it's questionable
you take a look at uh the ahmed arbory
case do you remember this one yes
fox news conservatives republicans came
out in defense of aubry and i was just
like well look i don't like the guy i
don't want the fact that anybody dies i
like the fact that he died but the story
is just we had a couple lawyers on who
broke it down for us and i'm like okay
so this guy was a burglar like yes he's
on camera committing a burglary yes and
so these guys were told by the police he
was the burglar yes so then when they
saw him they chased after him yes and
they were told that if they witnessed a
felony they could intervene to stop him
yes
but the police told them to stay stand
down while they while they came to
arrive and they didn't listen
and i'm like okay
and then what happened the guy who
filmed it got the remainder of his life
in prison and i'm like okay something
doesn't add up here
this story doesn't make sense so it's
not even a question of if if it's like i
mean the ahmed arbory case
should be very clear-cut in what
happened
but they will weaponize it and they will
lie about it and they will make it
questionable well and i i think that
just like
the left needs to keep a lot of their
people in check when it comes to
rioting when it comes to destroying
property and stuff like that we also we
do have a problem there have been plenty
of kids who have lost their life
unjustly and we need to talk about that
as well like the one i always think of
is tamira rice where it was like you
have like what a 13 year old kid playing
with a toy gun and i i think in law
enforcement i think
oh no is there something i don't know
yeah yeah don't tell me to me rice is
really like a 45 year old man no i think
he was uh
i think he had removed the orange tip
from the gun and he's five foot ten well
but he so here's what i was going to ask
the congressman from his law enforcement
um days
is i feel like
even if it is not
racism right there there is protocol
like
unless you feel like you are in
immediate danger you want to de-escalate
if you can't de-escalate you want to go
hands-on if you can't go hands-on you
want to go with taser and then in theory
pulling the gun should be
last or am i incorrect on that well
this is what i do know yes is there's
not a law enforcement officer in america
that's going to wake up tomorrow morning
and go to work evening each afternoon
that says i want to go out and legally
kill something i'm going to kill a kid i
want to go out there and legally kill
somebody today it's absolutely ludicrous
i think because that officer that has to
take that life they're going to live
with that for the rest of their life
even if it was a very dangerous
situation yes and the guy's pointing a
gun at you and and it's so difficult for
law enforcement today because of the
people that are mentally ill i mean you
have people that are mentally ill with
all the drugs the federal coming across
they're running around in streets naked
and they're chasing officers whether
it's a a small knife or even a piece of
glass and they're running at the officer
so the officers have a very difficult
time today and they have to make very
split you know second decision so did
you see the video actually and jamie you
see this where the news reporter goes to
the police conflict training uh
scenarios did you see this one no and so
the cop is like oh here's we're gonna do
we're gonna give you this mock weapon
that you know it fired like spitballs or
something or paintballs and they were
like you need to figure out when is the
appropriate like how to do a situation
oh no he so in the mock scenarios he
kills a guy several times and in one
he like sees a guy by a car and he's
like what are you doing and the guy
walks around the car and just pulls and
shoots and then the uh the cop goes
why'd you do that and he's like well
he was like he was just walking around a
car and he's like but i didn't know what
he was doing and i was worried it's like
the the reporter was like in every
circumstance he was given the reporter
actually killed the dude
unjustly
in one the guy just said something about
reporters though dry fair
like journalists
there was one moment where the guy gets
in his face like what are you doing man
get out of here and then he puts two in
his chest mockingly right and then the
cop is like what did you do you killed
them oh then everyone starts filming and
it's like thanks for checking out this
segment from the tim cast irl podcast
but if you want to check out the full
show live tune in monday through friday
at 8 pm and if you want more special
access content head over to timcast.com
and become a member your membership
helps sustain this company keep our
journalists employed makes this show
happen and you will get access to
exclusive members only segments of the
tim cast irl podcast and there's a
massive library to check out so again go
to timcast.com or tune in monday through
friday at 8 pm and we'll see you all
there
you